what is up everybody it's animac here
for anime uproar and bro I don't know if
I've ever witnessed the kind of crazy
roller coaster ride that Black Clover
just put us through just as it seemed
like the Spade Kingdom War Arc had fully
wrapped up and all the major tensions
have been resolved an absolute bombshell
hits Us in the very next chapter
multiple Bombshells actually a
three-month Hiatus for the manga has
been announced the next Arc is confirmed
to be the final Arc of the series and
then the big one the final villain of
Black Clover was revealed in absolutely
spectacular fashion this is insane we
need to talk about it right now you guys
know the drill if you enjoy our videos
you want to see more in the future leave
a like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps with the algorithm
and of course subscribing and hitting
that notification Bell is a completely
free way of directly supporting the
channel you can also hit me up on
Twitter Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar finally this video will of course
contain Black Clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so as I'm sure many of you
guys are aware of a large portion of the
Black Clover fan base was disappointed
with how the Spade Kingdom Arc ended and
I believe that some of the criticism is
absolutely valid don't get me wrong
there were definitely some good moments
in this Arc including the Austin liebe
moments the knocked and Yami moments and
so on but I was definitely not a fan of
mimosa basically becoming Shenron I was
also not a fan of Charlotte finally
confessing to Yami but him apparently
not even hearing her and let's be real
the villains were pretty big
disappointments Xenon was pretty good
but Dante and vanikar are just
one-dimensional psychos and Morris and
lucifero who were both so promising
ended up being extremely underwhelming
to me the only interesting villain ended
up being Adra Melech because he at least
doesn't appear to be completely
one-dimensional when he initially
appeared years he actually warns the
humans to get to safety instead of
attacking them he also refuses to follow
lucifero's orders even though we all
assumed that lucifero would be his
Superior and at the end of the battle he
not only passes up on the opportunity to
kill Asta he also Yanks out lucifero's
devil heart and flies away with it so
yeah adramelek seems like an interesting
character and it was clear that he would
return to the story again at some point
in the future but we had no idea just
how interesting he would turn out to be
in the very next chapter the latest
chapter chapter 331 is a sort of
epilogue or PostScript to the Spade
Kingdom War Arc and it leads into the
single biggest twist in the history of
Black Clover we start off with the
reveal that yuno's Mom Ciel grinberry
all is still alive apparently and she
just kind of shows up out of nowhere I
was under the impression that she was
killed back when the sograta siblings
took over but I guess not yuno's mom who
apparently hasn't aged at all in 17
years tells her son that he's become
such a fine young man and she then
proceeds to hug him now I would start
talking about how weird it is that we
are just finding out that she's alive
now since there was plenty of time for
the Spade guys like Ralph to reveal this
information to you know but let's just
move on because there's a lot more to
cover the Spade guys then bow to you
know and ask him to stay inside the
Spade Kingdom and help keep it safe but
yuno replies that he must first keep the
vows that he made to the Clover Kingdom
and to his rival osta elsewhere Asta
thanks liebe for allowing him to see his
mother lichita through liebe's memories
knowing that his mother really did love
him makes Asta happy and then liebe
thinks Asta in turn for helping him
avenge lichita's death this seems to
indicate that lucifero really is gone
for good A lot of people had speculated
that lucifero might return because he
never manifested fully into this world
only like half of his true power ever
made it out now I'm not sure if we're
gonna see him again or not but libis
seems to believe that they already
Avenged lichita which suggests that they
took lucifero out for good but we'll
have to wait and see as both Asta and
yuno renew their vow to become the
wizard King the chapter takes us back to
the Clover Kingdom capital we see damn
nacio Kira walking down the street and
then we see chibi Julius talking to Marx
via that hologram phone thingy Julius
says that the battle in the Spade
Kingdom had a good outcome overall and
that's great but Julius also seems to
genuinely believe that something just
doesn't add up when the conversation
ends and Julius is all alone we learned
that he's been feeling a strange and
powerful feeling of uneasiness for a
very long time but he can't quite put a
finger on it that is when Kira shows up
and asks to talk to Julius Kira says
that ever since Austin's trial following
the end of the elf Saga he has been
doing research into every documented
case of a devil host inside the Clover
Kingdom while digging through some
documents from like 20 years ago Kira
found out that there is no mention of
megikula as a supreme Devil Within the
cliffhop she is not one of the three
rulers of the underworld which is
something that we've talked about many
times before on this channel there are
three devil rulers and these are the
three most powerful Devils lucifero who
has gravity magic also known as Satan
Beelzebub who has spatial magic and
finally asteroth who has time magic Kira
believes that megikula may have taken
asteroth's place after he vanished from
the underworld and yes I always found it
strange that the three zograta siblings
were hosts to two of the rulers of the
underworld and yet vannica's devil
clearly had curse wording magic not time
magic so this meant that the Thai magic
devil had to be with someone else when
we learned that there was a fourth
zagrada sibling that's when we all
assumed that he must be the host of the
time devil Kira then brings up something
else that is very odd in all of his
research he has never found anyone else
who possessed time magic other than
Julius himself Kira is like Julius you
have nothing to do with this asteroth
time devil guy right right and Julius
with a genuinely sad slash Disturbed
expression on his face says you you're
right it really is me suddenly something
seems to be taking over julius's body
and he even tries to warn Kira but
before Kira can react that other
presence suddenly emerges and basically
pauses Kira's time freezing him in place
and then this other presence says the
words is that not how you wished things
were julius's coverless grimoire then
suddenly manifests a black Spade Kingdom
cover and this grimoire features two
paid symbols one on top of the other
Kira drops to the ground motionless and
suddenly through the window Adra Melech
appears still holding lucifero's heart
adramalek says everything happened
pretty much how you said it would Lucius
zogratus and the final page of the
chapter shows the face of the fourth
Socrates sibling he looks just like
adult Julius but with dark hair and
instead of the star-shaped mark on the
left side of his forehead he has a dark
sun-shaped mark on the right side of his
forehead Lucia smiles and says Ah time's
up and that is how the last chapter for
three months ends damn bro this was
intense I don't know what to say I
literally got goosebumps reading this
reveal it was easily the most exciting
twist I've ever seen in Black Clover and
one of the most exciting twists I've
experienced in Shonen manga as a whole
that said how all of this turns out will
depend on how the final Arc explains
everything and handles everything but
right now I think there is a lot of
potential for this series to go out with
a bang now about this crazy twist I know
quite a few people were predicting this
exact thing and one person that comes to
mind is Broku who has been a guest on
the channel before and who made a video
about this like many months ago the
clues were definitely there there was of
course the time magic connection and
there was also the fact that Julius
seemed to possess a second type of magic
which allowed him to transform his body
this implied that time magic might
actually come from a devil but it was
never confirmed personally I admit that
I didn't think this would happen just
because Julius has gone out of his way
to be a good guy many times he appeared
to be a genuine hero through and through
so I didn't think that all of this could
just be an act but depending on what
exactly is going on here there could be
an explanation for this the way I see it
there are two two major possible
scenarios first scenario Julius was evil
all along and he was just playing the
part of a noble and heroic wizard King
second scenario Julius has some sort of
split personality kind of like William
and patrie Lucius is a dark presence
inside of him that is able to take over
his body against his will and Julius may
not even be fully aware of what is going
on just like William wasn't julius's
initial reaction in this chapter seems
to suggest that this is the case he
talks about feeling uneasy but not
knowing why he seems to even try to warn
Kira that something is going on with his
body and the expression on his face
appears to show sincere confusion and
Dread as Lucia zogradis is taking over
also we have to remember that when
Julius is talking about feeling that
uneasiness he is completely alone in the
room so he's not putting up an act this
is definitely the scenario that I am
leaning towards right now because can
you really see Lucia zogratis risking
his own life in that fight against
Pottery like Julius did as Julius
himself said something doesn't add up
and if Julius is actually two people
that might explain why his grimoire has
two Spade symbols one on top of the
other instead of just one but then what
about asteroth apparently he has
completely disappeared from the
underworld meaning that he is probably
fully within this world just like liebe
so is Julius the host of three beings
himself Lucius and asteroth and what is
adramalek's role in all of this what is
Lucius about to do with lucifero's heart
I mean if asteroth is out there and has
his own heart why does he need luciferos
there are just so many massive pressing
questions right now and yet we're going
to have to wait at least three months
before getting any answers and that
freaking hurts what do you guys think
was Julius pulling an Eisen all along or
is he a genuinely good guy who somehow
became possessed by Lucius and asteroth
if so when do you think this happened
and is that related to the fact that the
fourth is the greatest sibling is no
longer in a wheelchair even though he
used to be in the flashbacks finally is
yuno's Mom the real-time magic devil
since she hasn't aged in 17 years you
guys definitely have to share your
thoughts down below even if you don't
normally comment on videos now is the
time to get into the discussion because
this is easily the craziest thing we've
ever seen in Black Clover and don't even
get me started on the theories that
Lucius or maybe even asteroth himself
could be asked as father because that is
even another level of absolute craziness
all criticism of the previous Arc aside
some of which was definitely legitimate
this was an exciting chapter to read and
I can't wait to see where the story goes
from here if you guys enjoyed this video
and you want to see more in the future
leave that like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps me
out and if you're new to the channel or
you watch our videos but you just
haven't gotten around to subscribing yet
remember that subscribing is a
completely free and direct way of
supporting the channel you can also hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime outpro patrons for
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to Kyle Salisbury he
is an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
Lord twigo himself and I can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including Alpha Sigma patehfa the
red-haired fox hinokami in water The
Toasted Chi Cory McGowan the Fallen
chosen Spidey life Danelle tungsten
tarkus and baked Buddhist finally thank
you also to our Pro Hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
Angel Cruz Alicia actor Bonnie Parks
Fatboy games kaido might be a duck
Jessica Rabbit olivania and Mando if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patreon exclusive Discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with the
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys
[Music]